Vìa định của Bö Đầu định mệnh của Tế một phазin dí tại Trung Quốc tổng MSI hàng hiểu khu chăm ha miếng.
Bình quan sẽ gọi tên tư trường nào.
Bối bà lính kẻ vĩ dịch LPL, Tế một đã dành trình thắng nét thử bà hài trước hả giống số một LPL anion legend.
Chính thức bí dành vào trận Trung Quốc tổng của MSI hàng hiểu khu chăm ha miếng.
Nơi họ sẽ chạm chắn kiếp phụm lịch thủ quen thuộc dây dí.
Đấy khu chỉ là của Bö Đầu địa trên ngôi vương MSI mà còn là trận trình hàng định mối vị,
bà chủ của khu quốc c c c c trước tình Trung Quốc tế dưới hàng hi khu chăm ha miếng.
Bí dành ra thấp hơn sau hình chính rắn tự nhiên của quốc.
Nhưng tên một đã tỷ hợi đánh khu chú kẻ hợi phía nha anion legend,
thuộc tổng của khu quốc bí diến và trận Trung Quốc tổng với phong thay khu khu khu khu khu khu khu CSS
kater tế bột năm sở.